Donc, nous avons commencé ce cours sur le thème « Craindre Dieu et non les hommes »
en examinant avec le pasteur Stéphane dans la première leçon ce qu'est la crainte de l'homme,
puis son opposé dans la deuxième leçon qui devrait caractériser nos vies chrétiennes, la crainte de Dieu.
Alors, je ne vais pas pouvoir revenir en détail sur ces leçons précédentes.
Je vous encourage à écouter les enregistrements pour ceux qui n'étaient pas présents.
Mais simplement, vous rappelez cette image que nous avons vue dans la leçon numéro 2
et que Christian nous a aussi rappelé dimanche dernier,
que pour le chrétien, craindre Dieu, il y a une part commune avec les non-croyants
qui est de considérer ce Dieu terrifiant qu'il est et qu'il sera toujours.
Mais avec en plus cette assurance d'être en sécurité au milieu de cette présence terrifiante qu'il est,
cette sécurité qu'il nous fournit lui-même en Jésus-Christ
et de pouvoir le contempler tel qu'il est, notre grand Dieu, un feu dévorant, terrifiant,
qui nous consumerait sur place.
Mais dans la présence de Christ, nous sommes en sécurité.
Nous sommes couverts de la justice de Christ.
Et nous pouvons contempler cette présence magnifique et terrifiante de Dieu en paix.
Et donc, la semaine dernière, nous sommes revenus sur la notion de la crainte de l'homme
pour l'approfondir en analysant plus spécifiquement la peur.
D'ailleurs, je vais faire un test, ce qui était là.
Nous avons vu trois facettes de la crainte de l'homme qu'elle peut revêtir dans notre vie.
Quelles étaient ces trois facettes ?
Oui, c'est la deuxième qu'on a vue, exposée en premier.
Et la troisième, blessée ou de souffrir.
Très bien.
Et donc, vous vous souvenez peut-être que j'avais précisé au début de ce cours la semaine dernière
que ce serait un cours assez descriptif.
On a défini pas mal de termes.
On a essayé d'expliquer toutes ces facettes que pouvait revêtir la crainte de l'homme
ou des hommes dans notre vie parce que le but, c'était de vous aider à identifier
certaines des formes de la crainte de l'homme contre lesquelles vous pouvez peut-être lutter dans votre vie.
Et donc, à partir d'aujourd'hui, nous allons commencer à passer à une partie plus pratique de ce sujet.
Et donc, pour cela, ce soir, nous allons répondre à une question qui paraît simple,
mais qui, nous allons le voir, n'est pas forcément aussi simple que ça à répondre.
De quoi avons-nous besoin ?
Quels sont nos besoins en tant qu'être humain ?
Alors, pourquoi aborder cette question qui, d'un premier abord, peut sembler un peu hors-sujet
par rapport au thème de la crainte de l'homme ?
Eh bien, parce qu'à la racine de nombreuses formes de craintes de l'homme
se trouve en réalité une grande confusion sur nos véritables besoins en tant qu'être humain.
Reprenons les trois exemples de la semaine dernière.
Et c'est particulièrement évident dans le cas de la peur du rejet.
Peut-être que vous avez vu plus jeune le film qui a été adapté du roman qui s'appelle
« Comment manger des vers de terre en une journée ».
Pas si certains l'ont vu.
Non ?
? Non ?
C'est la réponse ascétique.
Il s'agit en gros de se dire, c'est un mot un peu compliqué qui veut simplement dire, je n'ai pas de besoin.
Et le bouddhisme, c'est en fait la forme la plus classique et la plus institutionnalisée de cette réponse, parce que c'est une religion.
Le bonheur consiste ultimement à abandonner tout désir, à nier tout désir.
Et tant que je parviens à n'avoir aucun désir dans ma vie, alors je ne peux jamais être déçu, je ne peux jamais être frustré, frustré, triste.
Et donc, je peux rester dans une certaine forme de bonheur.
La deuxième mauvaise réponse qu'on peut apporter à cette question, de quoi ai-je besoin ? C'est la réponse hédoniste, comme souvent c'est l'inverse de la première.
L'être humain aime bien les extrêmes.
Et donc, l'hédonisme, c'est partir du principe que tout ce que je désire, c'est ce dont j'ai besoin.
Et je poursuis donc mes désirs sans retenue, afin de combler ces soi-disant besoins.
Et je sais qu'il semble peut-être ridicule que des chrétiens puissent adhérer à cette idée, mais pour prendre un peu de recul et ne pas aller trop vite dans nos réflexions,
pensez à la facilité avec laquelle nous transformons nos désirs en besoins, ne serait-ce que dans nos phrases.
« Je veux des vacances » devient « J'ai besoin de vacances ».
« Je veux être respecté » devient « J'ai besoin d'être respecté ».
« Je veux manger ce repas trop calorique pour la quatrième fois dans la semaine » devient « J'ai besoin de manger ».
« Je veux plus d'argent » devient « J'ai besoin de cette promotion que je mérite en plus ».
Nous transformons très rapidement, très facilement et souvent peut-être, des désirs forts, même des désirs qui sont légitimes, en besoins.
Équivalent à des besoins biologiques comme la nourriture ou l'eau, le fait de manger ou de boire.
Et lorsque nous faisons cela, nous devenons plus ou moins comme des hédonistes.
Nous transformons des désirs en besoins et nous poursuivons ces besoins, ou plutôt ces désirs, comme s'ils étaient des besoins essentiels à notre vie.
Et la troisième mauvaise réponse, c'est une combinaison des deux premières.
Et c'est probablement là que nous nous situons le plus souvent dans notre vie.
Nous divisons en gros nos désirs en deux catégories.
Ceux que nous allons nier, comme les ascètes, et ceux que nous allons traiter comme des besoins, comme les hédonistes.
Et pourtant, il n'y a pas de base biblique pour faire cette séparation.
C'est juste nous qui faisons une distinction, une séparation arbitraire de ce que nous pensons pouvoir supporter et ce que nous pensons ne pas pouvoir supporter.
pouvoir supporter. Une séparation entre ce dont nous pensons pouvoir nous passer et ce dont nous pensons ne pas pouvoir nous passer.
La vie chrétienne, vous vous en doutez, n'est pas ascétique et elle n'est pas hédoniste non plus.
Et ce n'est pas non plus un compromis pratique entre les deux.
Alors, que dit la Bible sur ce dont nous avons réellement besoin ?
Et comme très souvent, pour répondre à cette question, il nous faut commencer par définir ce qu'est un besoin.
De quoi ai-je besoin ? C'est en réalité une question un peu plus complexe que ce qui n'y paraît dans un premier temps.
Et donc, qu'est-ce qu'un besoin ?
Si vous étiez perdu dans le désert et que je vous posais cette question, probablement que vous répondriez, j'ai besoin d'eau.
D'eau. Et ça serait très pertinent comme réponse.
Si je vous posais cette même question durant une étude biblique comme ce soir, vous diriez sans doute, j'ai besoin de Jésus pour être sauvé.
Si vous vous trouviez au milieu d'une dispute avec votre conjoint ou un ami ou un collègue,
peut-être que vous diriez, j'ai besoin de quelqu'un qui m'écoute, quelqu'un qui me comprend.
Et si quelqu'un vous posait cette question au détour d'une conversation,
où vous êtes à cœur ouvert, vous êtes honnête l'un envers l'autre autour d'un café,
qui sait ce que vous répondriez à cette même question ?
J'ai besoin de respect, j'ai besoin d'amour, j'ai besoin de compréhension, j'ai besoin d'estime de moi,
j'ai besoin que mes enfants soient obéissants, j'ai besoin de sécurité financière, d'aventure,
j'ai besoin de ressentir de l'excitation dans ma vie.
La liste que nous dressons de nos besoins est potentiellement infinie.
Et cette liste de ce dont nous avons besoin écrit Ed Welch dans le livre que j'ai beaucoup cité dans le dernier cours,
et que je citerai encore ce soir, quand les hommes ont plus d'importance que Dieu,
écrit la chose suivante à ce sujet.
« Cette liste que nous dressons de nos besoins n'est limitée que par l'imagination et les désirs humains. »
Bienvenue dans le monde du mot « besoin », l'un des termes les plus confus de la langue française.
Tout le monde l'utilise, mais il peut exprimer des idées totalement différentes et sans aucun lien entre elles. »
Fin de citation.
De l'eau à Jésus en passant par la compréhension des autres envers nous, l'argent ou l'aventure,
cette liste est aussi infinie que variée.
Et donc, intéressons-nous à trois différentes catégories de besoins.
Les besoins biologiques, les besoins spirituels et les besoins psychologiques.
Tout d'abord, les besoins biologiques.
La Bible en parle fréquemment.
Par exemple, dans le serment sur la montagne, Jésus nous dit
« de ne pas nous inquiéter de ce que nous allons manger ou porter comme vêtements,
car, » je cite, « votre Père céleste sait que vous en avez besoin. »
Donc, dans ce verset, Jésus ne nie pas le besoin.
Et d'ailleurs, il ne promet pas, dans ce verset en tout cas, que Dieu va pourvoir à ce besoin,
mais il promet que Dieu lui connaît ce besoin.
Les besoins biologiques sont assez simples, si on devait les résumer.
Il s'agit de tout ce dont nous avons réellement besoin pour rester en vie.
Manger, boire, pour avoir une bonne santé qui permet un fonctionnement correct de notre corps.
Ne pas mourir.
Voilà.
Et une petite subtilité, cependant, peut-être pour traiter une idée que vous avez pu croiser dans votre vie,
c'est que cette catégorie, elle est quelque part si évidente qu'on est paradoxalement tenté d'y faire entrer d'autres choses.
Toujours Ed Welch écrit, « Prenons l'exemple courant de cette phrase, j'ai besoin de sexe, de relation sexuelle. »
Lorsque l'on fait passer cela de la catégorie du désir ou de la convoitise, si on parle de péché,
à la catégorie du besoin biologique,
on suppose que la relation sexuelle est un besoin biologique presque au même titre que la nourriture et l'eau.
Fin de citation.
Mais si c'était vraiment le cas,
comment devrions-nous comprendre les interdictions bibliques concernant les relations sexuelles en dehors du mariage ?
Si ces relations étaient réellement un besoin biologique au même titre que boire ou manger,
cela reviendrait à dire que Dieu, dans sa parole, nous ordonne de nous priver d'un besoin essentiel à notre vie elle-même,
au même titre que boire ou manger.
C'est une sorte de parenthèse pour vous montrer comment on peut mal utiliser ce terme ou abuser de ce terme « besoin ».
Les besoins spirituels maintenant.
Elle doit être bien connue cette catégorie et on ira assez rapidement dessus car elle est plus évidente,
bien connue de vous qui êtes des lecteurs de la Bible, les besoins spirituels.
Et l'Écriture est sans pitié quand elle décrit notre situation spirituelle.
Nous sommes morts dans nos fautes et nos péchés, Éphésiens 2.
Nous sommes aussi impuissants qu'un bébé abandonné, Ézéchiel 16.
Nous sommes esclaves du péché, Romain 6.
Mais la bonne nouvelle, bien sûr, c'est que Dieu ne nous a pas laissé seul face à nos besoins spirituels irrésolus,
mais qu'il a pourvu à tout pour y répondre en Jésus-Christ.
« Deux pierres 1, verset 3. »
Sa divine puissance nous a donné tout ce qui contribue à la vie et à la piété. »
Et troisième catégorie, un peu plus délicate et sur laquelle nous allons nous arrêter un peu plus, du coup,
les besoins psychologiques.
Toujours Ed Welch, même, écrit « La liste des besoins psychologiques peut être longue,
mais elle concerne généralement ce que nous voulons dans nos relations.
Importance, acceptation, respect, admiration, amour, appartenance, sens, etc. »
Certains réduisent cette longue liste à un seul besoin, le besoin d'amour.
Très souvent, nous traitons les besoins psychologiques comme s'ils étaient aussi fondamentaux à l'existence humaine que les besoins biologiques.
D'un point de vue chrétien, nous dirions que Dieu lui-même est un être relationnel,
ayant existé de toute éternité dans une parfaite communion entre le Père, le Fils, le Saint-Esprit.
Et donc ainsi, en créant l'humanité à son image, il nous a créés en tant qu'êtres relationnels
pour que nous établissions des relations entre nous.
Après tout, il n'est pas bon que l'homme soit seul, Genèse 1.
Par conséquent, nous avons besoin d'être aimés, acceptés, valorisés, pour nous sentir bien dans notre peau,
pour être heureux, pour nous sentir accomplis, épanouis en tant qu'êtres humains.
Cela est inscrit dans notre nature humaine.
On pourrait décrire cette vision des choses comme le modèle du ver d'amour sur lequel on reviendra plus tard.
Le modèle du ver d'amour de l'être humain, de l'humanité.
Si je suis aimé, mon ver d'amour se remplit, je suis heureux et je suis capable d'aimer les autres en retour.
Et si ce n'est pas le cas, alors je suis un ver vide, incapable d'être ce que je devrais être envers les autres.
Nos batteries psychologiques ou émotionnelles doivent être rechargées afin que nous puissions fonctionner normalement.
Je ne dis pas que cela est vrai, je suis en train de vous expliquer cette vision des choses.
Et maintenant, certains chrétiens pourraient faire remarquer que cette vision des choses
semble nous rendre très dépendants des autres êtres humains, de nos relations avec eux et surtout de leur attitude envers nous.
Et chaque fois que nous avons besoin de quelque chose d'autre que Dieu,
cela nous place dans une situation dangereuse de dépendance, une pente glissante qui peut mener à l'idolâtrie.
Et les chrétiens qui font cette observation seraient donc d'accord avec le postulat principal
que nous avons en nous un besoin psychologique, relationnel, légitime d'amour,
mais insisteraient sur le fait que l'amour dont le Christ nous aime suffit à combler ce besoin,
que la relation que nous avons avec Christ suffit pleinement.
Nous sommes l'épouse du Christ, pourrait-on entendre.
Nous n'avons donc besoin de personne d'autre pour combler ces besoins psychologiques, ce besoin d'amour.
Alors, quel est le problème avec la théorie du verre d'amour ?
Comme vous pouvez l'imaginer après ce que je viens de décrire, cette théorie pose de sérieux problèmes.
Qu'on la présente dans sa version simple ou dans la version plus élaborée,
Jésus comble tous mes besoins psychologiques.
Voici trois difficultés majeures avec cette façon de voir les choses, de voir nos besoins psychologiques.
Concentrez-vous sur la première, la phrase est un peu compliquée.
Donc, tout d'abord, cette théorie du verre d'amour tend à faire passer un désir inassouvi en nous
pour une cause aussi déterminante de notre péché que notre propre cœur pécheur.
Vous allez mieux comprendre quand je vais l'expliquer.
Par exemple, imaginons quelqu'un qui a du mal à contrôler ses accès de colère,
qui manque de maîtrise de lui-même.
Mais quand on le confronte par rapport à ce péché, il en attribue la cause à autre chose.
Par exemple, mais ma femme ne me respecte jamais, elle ne m'aime pas.
C'est pour ça que je m'emporte si facilement.
Ou, comme David le dit souvent, j'ai du sang italien qui coule dans mes veines, je suis un sanguin.
Je m'emporte vite et fort.
Mais nous savons, d'après la Bible, que la cause du péché, c'est le péché.
C'est le péché.
Et si l'on classe le fait de vouloir, vouloir le désir, être respecté par notre femme dans la catégorie des désirs bons et légitimes,
alors, si ce désir n'est pas comblé, nous serons déçus.
Ce qui peut engendrer une tentation à la colère.
Et céder à cette colère, eh bien, c'est céder au péché.
Et c'est donc péché.
Ça, c'est ce qui se passe si on garde cette raison.
Ma femme ne me respecte pas dans la catégorie du désir.
Mais si l'on considère qu'être respecté par sa femme, c'est un besoin,
alors l'absence de ce respect justifie la colère.
Car ce n'est plus un désir, mais un besoin.
Et donc, le fait de raisonner comme ça minimise la dimension de rébellion contre Dieu, qui est propre au péché,
et encourage à rejeter la faute sur les autres ou les circonstances, qu'elles soient intérieures ou extérieures à nous-mêmes.
Premier problème avec cette théorie du ver d'amour.
Ensuite, deuxième problème, cette théorie ne correspond tout simplement pas à la manière dont la Bible décrit ce qui doit nous motiver à aimer.
Nous ne sommes pas appelés à aimer les autres parce qu'ils ont besoin de notre amour,
et encore moins dans l'espoir qu'en retour ils nous combleront de leur amour,
et encore moins parce qu'ils nous ont d'abord comblés d'amour.
Jean 4, verset 19 déclare
« Nous aimons parce qu'il nous a aimés le premier » en parlant de Jésus-Christ, de Dieu.
Et même ce verset peut être mal compris par rapport à ce que je viens de dire.
Il ne faut pas le lire comme s'il disait
« Jésus m'a aimé, cela a comblé mon besoin d'amour,
je suis rempli d'amour,
mon ver d'amour est rempli,
donc je suis désormais libre d'aimer les autres. »
Ce serait tout simplement la version chrétienne modifiée de cette théorie du ver d'amour.
Non, l'amour selon la Bible ne nous libère pas seulement,
il nous pousse irrésistiblement à aimer,
malgré notre chair qui réside souvent à cet élan de notre cœur régénéré.
L'amour de Dieu en nous nous pousse à aimer,
même contre notre chair, à aimer Dieu et à aimer notre prochain.
Écoutez par exemple l'explication de l'apôtre Paul en 2 Corinthiens,
chapitre 5, versets 14 à 15.
« Car l'amour de Christ nous presse,
parce que nous estimons que si un seul est mort pour tous,
tous donc sont morts,
et qu'il est mort pour tous,
afin que ceux qui vivent ne vivent plus pour eux-mêmes,
mais pour celui qui est mort et ressuscité pour eux. »
Ou encore, l'évangile de Luc, chapitre 7, verset 47.
« Celui à qui on pardonne peu, aime peu,
mais celui à qui il a été beaucoup pardonné, aime beaucoup. »
Si vous avez été pardonné par Dieu,
vous ne pouvez faire autrement qu'aimer Dieu
et aimer votre prochain.
Un manque d'amour pour Dieu révèle soit un cœur qui n'a pas été pardonné,
soit un cœur, ça arrive aussi chez les chrétiens,
qui ignore à quel point il a été pardonné.
Mais la réalité biblique, c'est que le pardon divin nous pousse à aimer.
Même si nous n'en avons pas la force,
et nous n'en avons souvent pas la force,
même si nous ne nous sentons pas remplis d'amour,
l'amour de Dieu pour nous,
le pardon de Dieu pour nous,
nous pousse irrésistiblement à aimer.
Nous ne restons pas passifs
à attendre que nos besoins psychologiques soient comblés par Jésus
ou par qui que ce soit avant d'aimer.
Nous aimons parce qu'il nous a aimés le premier.
Nous aimons parce que nous ne pouvons pas faire autrement,
car il vit désormais en nous
avec toute la plénitude de son amour parfait.
Et cet amour nous presse à aimer Dieu et notre prochain.
Et troisièmement,
troisième problème avec cette théorie,
le modèle du vers d'amour inverse
la direction du commandement biblique d'aimer.
Au lieu d'être un appel à aimer,
donc de nous vers les autres,
il devient une revendication à être aimé,
des autres vers nous.
Se considérer comme lésé
parce que les autres ne nous aiment pas,
ce n'est tout simplement pas biblique.
Il vaudrait mieux être plus honnête en affirmant,
et plus juste quelque part,
en affirmant que les autres ont le devoir biblique de nous aimer.
Dieu commande cela à chacun de ses enfants.
Il vaudrait mieux dire cela
que de prétendre que nous avons en nous
un besoin d'être aimé,
et un besoin qui doit donc être répondu,
auquel il faut répondre.
Et si on appliquait cette même logique,
par exemple,
au commandement de regarder les autres
comme supérieurs à vous-même,
est-ce que cela voudrait alors dire
que nous avons en nous
un besoin créé par Dieu
d'être regardés comme étant supérieurs aux autres,
et que les autres doivent d'abord
nous regarder comme supérieurs à eux
avant que nous-mêmes nous puissions les regarder
comme supérieurs à nous ?
Vous voyez que manifestement,
cette ligne d'argumentation,
cette façon de penser,
ne tient pas.
Alors tout ce que je dis là
peut sembler se rapprocher un peu trop
de la vision bouddhiste
de la vie chrétienne,
que j'ai critiqué plus tôt,
comme si la solution,
c'était de faire semblant
qu'on a besoin de personne,
qu'on n'a aucun besoin relationnel,
mais ce serait aller trop loin
dans l'autre sens.
Ce que je veux éviter en réalité,
c'est cette idée
que nous aurions des besoins psychologiques
comparables aux besoins biologiques.
Si bien que sans avoir d'abord reçu
quelque chose qui vient de quelqu'un d'autre,
il nous serait impossible
d'être heureux ou en bonne santé,
ou que sans avoir d'abord reçu
une quantité suffisante
d'énergie positive
ou d'amour d'autrui,
nous serions incapables
d'aimer comme la Bible
nous commande de le faire.
Et c'est là qu'il est crucial
d'introduire la distinction
entre un besoin et un désir.
Une grande partie
de notre culture moderne
considère comme des besoins psychologiques
des choses qui sont en réalité des désirs,
parfois de bons désirs,
des désirs légitimes
que Dieu a créés,
mais qui restent des désirs
et qui ne sont pas des besoins
et que nous ne devons pas transformer
comme des besoins.
La différence entre un besoin et un désir,
elle se voit bien à notre réaction
lorsque nous ne recevons pas
ce que nous voulons.
Alors, c'est plus dur à voir aujourd'hui
dans une société qui a tellement transformé
des désirs en besoins.
mais quand on vous prive de quelque chose
que vous désirez simplement,
vous êtes frustré, vous êtes déçu,
vous êtes triste.
Mais si vous croyez ou constatez
qu'on vous a privé de quelque chose
dont vous avez besoin,
manger, boire, respirer,
on pourrait même inclure le fait
de marcher en liberté,
alors vous êtes bien plus
que simplement déçu,
vous êtes en colère.
Vous pouvez même être justement
paniqué par la situation
parce que cela devient une question
de justice,
voire de vie ou de mort.
C'est un besoin
et ce n'est plus une préférence,
ce n'est plus un souhait,
ce n'est plus un désir.
Ed Welch le résume bien à nouveau.
Quand nous désirons être respectés
et que ce respect ne nous est pas accordé,
nous sommes blessés.
Mais si nous considérons
que le respect est un besoin,
alors nous sommes dévastés,
nous sommes en colère.
Si l'amour des autres pour nous
était un réel besoin,
on s'attendrait à le trouver
dans les nombreuses prières de la Bible.
Or, on trouve bien des prières
pour des besoins biologiques,
des besoins spirituels,
mais pas pour des besoins psychologiques.
Prenons par exemple
la prière que notre Seigneur Jésus-Christ
nous a donnée comme modèle
pour toute autre prière
en Matthieu, chapitre 6.
Notre Père qui es aux cieux,
que ton nom soit sanctifié,
que ton règne vienne,
que ta volonté soit faite
sur la terre comme au ciel.
Donne-nous aujourd'hui
notre pain quotidien.
Pardonne-nous nos offenses,
comme nous aussi nous pardonnons
à ceux qui nous ont offensés.
ne nous soumets pas à la tentation,
mais délivre-nous du mal.
Est-ce que Jésus pense
que nos besoins sont importants ?
Absolument.
Nous prions pour notre pain quotidien,
pour le pardon,
pour être délivrés du mal.
Besoins biologiques,
besoins spirituels.
Mais on ne voit aucune reconnaissance
d'un besoin que les autres nous respectent,
que les autres nous approuvent,
nous félicitent, nous aiment.
Au lieu de valider notre revendication
de besoin d'être aimé,
l'Écriture nous appelle simplement à aimer.
Tout simplement parce que nous avons déjà été aimés
parfaitement,
infiniment,
par l'être le plus digne et aimable qui soit,
par Dieu lui-même.
En comblant nos besoins biologiques
et surtout spirituels,
Dieu a comblé et comble chaque jour
nos besoins psychologiques,
affectifs et émotionnels.
Je m'arrête ici.
Si vous avez des questions,
pas beaucoup,
on pourra garder le temps à la fin,
mais une ou deux questions
pour y répondre avant de continuer.
Paul, oui ?
Est-ce que je peux juste répéter
la phrase du tout à l'heure ?
La théorie du genre d'amour
fort à temps passé
pendant des heures inassolies
ont une cause
de ce qui est terminé ?
Il faut que je retrouve.
Ah oui ?
Si je ne la trouve pas là,
je te la donnerai après.
D'accord.
Là, je vais…
Sinon, je vais me perdre en mes notes,
donc je pourrais te donner ça juste après.
Tu me redemandes à la fin.
Oui.
Est-ce qu'un…
Quand on parle de besoins,
là, on parle de besoins personnels.
Parce que j'ai la question.
Quand tu parlais, par exemple,
de voir la relation sexuelle,
est-ce que l'humanité,
la civilisation a besoin
de relation sexuelle quelque part
pour survivre ?
Du coup, est-ce que quelque chose
qui n'est pas un besoin personnel
peut devenir un besoin
à plus grand effet ?
C'est un sujet évidemment très complexe.
Dans le cadre des cours
d'une heure max,
le vendredi soir,
on ne peut pas rentrer
dans tous les détails,
mais effectivement,
là, on est dans le contexte
de besoins individuels,
on va dire.
Et même,
le but est surtout
de faire la comparaison
entre…
ou plutôt de bien clarifier
la distinction
entre besoins et désirs.
et la réalité,
c'est que même si ça peut être difficile
ou qu'il peut y avoir
des complications par rapport à ça,
une personne peut vivre
sans ses relations sexuelles.
Une personne ne peut pas vivre
sans manger ou boire,
en tout cas,
pas longtemps.
Donc, c'est vraiment
pour essayer
de bien catégoriser
ces choses-là,
surtout dans une génération,
une société
où le mélange a été
vraiment fait
profondément
et depuis longtemps.
si bien que parfois,
on ne fait plus la distinction
et qu'on voit,
comme je le disais,
des personnes qui réagissent
à des privations
de leurs désirs
comme si c'était
des privations de besoins
et qui donc tombent
dans des crises existentielles
ou des manifestations
de colère démesurées
parce qu'elles considèrent
des désirs
comme des besoins.
Bien,
s'il n'y a pas d'autres questions,
on va continuer.
Oui.
Quand tu crois
le besoin psychologique
comme
qu'on considérait
le besoin psychologique
le besoin d'amour,
tu dirais que
tu avais dit que
en fait,
ce besoin
qu'on a d'être aimé
finalement
est déjà comblé
donc
est naturellement comblé
par Dieu.
Du coup,
on n'est pas censé
avoir d'autres
désirs
enfin,
ressentir un besoin
d'être aimé par les autres.
C'est ça ?
Pour préciser,
là,
le point de secours,
c'est vraiment
pour mettre en évidence
le fait que,
notamment dans ce domaine
des désirs
ou besoins psychologiques,
ça dépend comment
on les considère,
on ne doit pas attendre
quand on lit
l'enseignement biblique
à ce sujet
de d'abord être comblé
par les autres
avant d'agir nous-mêmes.
Dieu nous a déjà
parfaitement aimé.
Nous avons cette source-là
disponible
à profusion
en Christ
et c'est surtout
et comme je disais,
c'était important
de faire la précision,
ce n'est pas comme si
on disait
non mais Dieu a fait ça,
c'est-à-dire
qu'il m'a rempli d'amour
donc je peux en donner
aux autres.
C'est que l'amour
de Christ vit en nous
et nous presse
à aimer les autres.
Donc c'est différent,
tu vois,
il y a une nuance
et le point c'est vraiment
de dire
on ne doit pas dépendre
ou penser qu'on dépend
ou prétendre
avancer le fait
qu'on dépend
de recevoir
d'abord des autres
pour avoir suffisamment
pour donner aux autres
en retour.
Dieu a déjà accompli
tout ce qui était nécessaire
pour qu'on ait ce qu'il faut
pour donner aux autres
même si personne
ne nous donne rien.
Donc voilà,
comme je disais,
il y a surtout
sur cette notion
de besoin
parce que Dieu
nous a créés
avec des besoins,
des désirs,
comme je dis,
il y en a qui sont légitimes,
c'est légitime de désirer
et je crois qu'on le dira
un peu plus tard,
ces relations-là
d'amour, etc.,
de reconnaissance
des autres
mais l'idée,
c'est que ça ne doit
jamais être
une dépendance
et surtout
qui doit être
comblée
ou un besoin
soi-disant
qui doit être comblée
avant que nous
on puisse faire
ce que Dieu
nous demande de faire.
On doit être proactif,
on a tout ce qu'il faut
à notre disposition
en crise
pour le faire
et le reste,
quelque part,
c'est du bonus.
Le fait de recevoir
des autres,
c'est du bonus.
On va continuer
avec le point 4.
Qui êtes-vous ?
Notre question courte
n'est pas forcément simple.
Donc,
on ne peut pas
s'arrêter à ce stade.
J'ai peut-être réussi
à vous démontrer
que la Bible
ne soutient pas
ce modèle psychologique
du verre d'amour,
mais je ne vous ai pas
encore dit quoi faire
de ces sentiments
que vous ressentez
et qui peut-être
vous troublent.
Ce désir de sécurité
qui, lorsqu'il est menacé,
se manifeste
par la peur
d'être exposé,
rejeté ou blessé
par les autres.
Nous craignons les gens
parce qu'ils peuvent
nous exposer
et nous humilier.
Nous les craignons
parce qu'ils peuvent
nous rejeter,
nous ridiculiser
ou nous mépriser.
Nous les craignons
parce qu'ils peuvent
nous attaquer
ou nous menacer.
Que faire de toutes ces choses
qui sont bien réelles
dans notre vie ?
Pour le comprendre,
en plus d'identifier
nos besoins réels,
nous devons aussi
identifier
quel est l'objectif
ultime
de notre vie.
Car pour faire
un peu de mathématiques
spirituelles,
l'équation de la peur
des hommes,
c'est la suivante.
Si je ne peux pas
avoir X,
je ne peux pas
être heureux.
ou si Y se produit,
alors je serai anéanti
et je ne pourrai
plus jamais aller bien.
Ces deux affirmations
présupposent un but
dans la vie.
Être heureux
et aller bien.
Alors,
quel est le but
que Dieu a en vue
pour nos vies ?
Revenons à Genèse 1,
au début de la Bible.
Dieu crée
tous les êtres vivants
selon leur espèce.
Chaque pomme
est modelée
selon une autre pomme,
chaque zèbre
selon un autre zèbre,
mais lorsqu'il s'agit
de créer l'être humain,
c'est différent.
Dieu dit,
Genèse 1, verset 26,
faisons l'homme
à notre image,
selon notre ressemblance
et qu'il domine
sur les poissons
de la mer,
les oiseaux du ciel,
sur le bétail,
sur toute la terre
et sur tous les reptiles
qui rampent
sur la terre.
Dieu créa l'homme
à son image.
Il le créa
à l'image de Dieu.
Il les créa
hommes et femmes.
Nous sommes faits
à l'image de Dieu
selon sa ressemblance.
Une image de Dieu
qui reflète Dieu lui-même.
Que signifie refléter Dieu ?
Cela signifie
refléter
qui il est.
Notre être même
proclame quelque chose
de l'être de Dieu.
Votre but
en tant que créature humaine
est de manifester
la gloire
et la bonté
de Dieu,
votre créateur.
en tant qu'être humain,
vous faites cela
en agissant comme Dieu,
en l'imitant,
en aimant,
en faisant miséricorde,
en créant,
en enseignant,
en prenant soin
de la création,
etc.
Mais vous n'êtes pas seulement,
nous ne sommes pas seulement
des êtres humains,
nous sommes aussi
des êtres rachetés,
en cours de transformation
à l'image de Christ.
Et en tant que chrétien,
vous manifestez
la gloire de Dieu
non seulement
par votre humanité,
mais aussi
par votre humanité
rachetée,
par votre cœur nouveau,
un cœur de chair
qui vous retransforme
à l'image
de votre créateur.
En tant que porteur
de son image,
votre vie
manifeste
la puissance
et la sagesse
de Dieu.
En tant que porteur
d'images
rachetées,
votre vie
manifeste aussi
sa miséricorde
et sa grâce.
William Shakespeare
a écrit
« Le monde entier
est un théâtre
et tous,
hommes et femmes,
n'y sont que des acteurs. »
Et c'est plus vrai
que ce qu'il n'imaginait
probablement
lorsqu'il a dit ça.
Votre but dans la vie
est de montrer
l'excellence
de notre grand Dieu.
Dans cette pièce
de théâtre
qui est la vie,
qui est le monde,
sa création
et dont il est
le metteur en scène.
Votre bonheur,
votre épanouissement,
votre utilité
peuvent jouer
un rôle
dans tout cela,
mais aucune
de ces choses
n'est votre but
ultime.
Votre but
ultime,
c'est de refléter,
de représenter
et de glorifier
votre Créateur
et votre Rédempteur,
le Dieu Trinitaire.
Dieu nous appelle
à être heureux.
C'est une certitude.
Il nous a créés
pour que nous le soyons.
Mais ce n'est pas
le but principal
de notre vie,
c'est plutôt
le résultat
du fait d'atteindre
le but principal
de notre vie
qui est
de glorifier Dieu.
Si nous glorifions
Dieu dans notre vie,
alors nous serons
véritablement heureux.
Quelle est la fin
principale
et la plus élevée
de l'homme ?
Première question
du catéchisme
de Westminster,
de glorifier Dieu
et de trouver
pleinement
sa part
et sa joie
en lui
à jamais.
Alors,
de quoi avons-nous
réellement
ou vraiment
besoin ?
Quand nous répondons
à la question
de quoi avons-nous besoin,
il nous faut répondre
en fonction
de ce but
pour lequel Dieu
nous a créés.
De quoi avons-nous
besoin
pour refléter
l'excellence,
la gloire
et la bonté
de Dieu ?
De quoi avons-nous
besoin
pour glorifier Dieu ?
Eh bien,
nos besoins biologiques
s'intègrent
bien dans ce but.
psaume 6
que nous avons lu
en introduction
dit
« Parmi les morts,
qui invoque ton nom ? »
Qui te loue
dans le séjour des morts ?
Et donc,
nous devons vivre
pour invoquer
le nom de l'Éternel
et c'est d'ailleurs
pour cela
que notre salut
s'achèvera
par la vie éternelle
pour que nous puissions
glorifier Dieu
éternellement.
Et nos besoins
spirituels aussi.
Dans le psaume 51,
David demande
pardon à Dieu.
Pourquoi ?
Il dit « Alors j'enseignerai
tes voies aux transgresseurs
et les pécheurs
reviendront à toi. »
Dieu est glorifié
lorsqu'il répond
à nos besoins
biologiques et spirituels
par nos cœurs reconnaissants,
parce que nous louons
sa provision
aux yeux des hommes
et parce qu'en répondant
à ses besoins,
il nous maintient en vie
physiquement et spirituellement
afin que nous reflétions
son image.
Et les besoins psychologiques
alors dans tout cela ?
Quel lien ont-ils
avec notre but
de glorifier Dieu
en tant qu'être humain ?
À nouveau,
Ed Welch,
il l'exprime ainsi
« En dehors du pardon
des péchés,
avons-nous des besoins ?
Avons-nous besoin
de relations ? »
Cela dépend
de ce qu'on entend
par « besoin ».
Si nous parlons
de besoins psychologiques,
alors non,
nous n'avons pas besoin
de relations,
ni avec Dieu,
ni avec les hommes,
pour combler notre soif
de reconnaissance
ou d'amour.
Ce serait comme dire
que j'ai besoin
de Dieu
pour satisfaire mon désir
de me sentir important.
Les besoins égoïstes
ne sont pas faits
pour être comblés,
mais pour être mis à mort.
Fin de citation.
Je n'ai pas besoin
des autres
pour combler
un vide existentiel en moi.
Encore une fois,
Ed Welch,
pour terminer,
l'image de Dieu
en nous
ne concerne pas
un besoin psychologique,
mais l'abondance
de dons que Dieu
a accordé à son peuple.
Dieu a placé
son image en nous
pour que nous puissions
bénir notre prochain
et le glorifier.
Cela signifie
que dans un sens,
nous avons besoin
des autres,
oui,
mais pas pour remplir
un manque en nous,
pour accomplir
le but pour lequel
Dieu nous a créés.
Quand il nous a créés
à son image,
il nous a créés
ensemble.
Il a créé l'humanité
Adam et Ève,
Genèse 1,
verset 27,
à nouveau,
à l'image de Dieu,
il le créa,
hommes et femmes,
il les créa.
Représenter,
refléter,
le Dieu trinitaire
n'est pas quelque chose
que nous pouvons faire
seuls.
Dieu a créé l'humanité
en tant que communauté.
Dans la Genèse,
nous reflétons Dieu
en tant que famille.
En ce qui concerne Jésus,
nous le reflétons
aussi comme famille
et nous sommes aussi
la famille de Dieu,
l'Église.
Nous avons été créés
avec des dons
et des capacités limitées.
Aucun de nous ne possède
tous les dons de Dieu.
C'est pourquoi
nous avons besoin
des autres
pour accomplir
les desseins de Dieu
et refléter au mieux
sa gloire infinie.
Citation encore
de Edward Welch.
pour conclure
cette quatrième leçon.
Avons-nous besoin
d'un certain niveau
de confidentialité
pour ne plus,
enfin,
pour ne plus craindre
ceux qui pourraient
nous exposer
ou nous humilier ?
Non.
C'est une chose
tout à fait légitime
à désirer,
mais ce n'est pas un besoin.
Nous pouvons vivre
sans ça.
car nous savons en plus
que Dieu peut se servir
même de notre humiliation
pour nous sanctifier
et pour se glorifier
en accomplissant
ses desseins ultimes,
tout comme il l'a fait
avec son Fils
qui a été exposé
et humilié
pour notre salut.
Même si Dieu nous appelle
à l'humiliation
la plus grande
dans notre vie,
nous pouvons lui faire confiance.
Cela servira
notre bien ultime
et sa gloire ultime.
Avons-nous besoin
de nous sentir inclus
au point de ne plus
craindre ceux
qui pourraient
nous rejeter,
nous ridiculiser,
nous mépriser ?
Non.
Ce sont des choses
qu'il est bon de vouloir,
mais ce ne sont pas
des besoins.
De même que Dieu a permis
que son Fils soit rejeté
pour nous,
par lui-même.
Nous savons
qu'il peut se servir
du rejet
dans notre vie
pour notre bien ultime
et pour sa gloire ultime.
Et qu'en est-il
de notre sécurité
physique notamment?
Bien sûr
que Dieu s'en soucie.
Jésus dit que
Dieu nourrit les oiseaux
et habille les fleurs,
alors ne prendra-t-il
pas soin de nous aussi?
Et pourtant,
plus encore
que de répondre
à nos besoins biologiques,
Dieu tient
à ce que nous accomplissions
notre but
de créature humaine.
Et dans son soin souverain,
il permettra parfois
que nous souffrions.
Dieu ne nous a jamais promis
que nous n'allions pas souffrir.
au contraire,
il nous a promis
l'inverse
en tant que ses disciples.
Mais il nous a promis
de toujours être avec nous,
même dans les pires souffrances,
peut-être surtout
dans les pires souffrances.
Nous n'avons donc
pas besoin
de craindre la souffrance.
C'est la différence
entre le scalpel du chirurgien
et le couteau du criminel.
Chaque souffrance
qui nous atteint
a été soigneusement
mesurée,
pesée
est prescrite
avec amour
par le grand médecin,
notre Père Céleste,
dont la joie
est de nous rendre saints
pour notre propre joie.
C'est en devenant saints
que nous devenons heureux
et que Dieu
est glorifié
à travers nos vies.
et que Dieu